>>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S TRY TO GET THIS NEXT SHOT
IN BEFORE LUNCH.
I THREW MY BREAKFAST AT MY
ASSISTANT, SO I'M STARVING.
TOMMY, I WANT YOU DANCING UP
TOP.
CAMERA THEN CUTS TO MARIO.
YOU'RE POURING EVERYONE'S SHOTS.
THEN JAMAL, YOU TOAST MARIO.
SOUND GOOD?
YEAH.
>> PLACES.
ACTION.
>> LIVING WITH HIV?
I LEARNED I COULD SAY
UNDETECTABLE WITH FEWER
MEDICINES.
>> MOST HIV PILLS HAVE SO MANY
MEDICINES, BUT DOVA THE, O HAS
LESS, AND IT'S JUST AS
EFFECTIVE.
>> THAT'S WHY I SWITCHED TO
DOVATO HIV TREATMENT.
I AIN'T GAY, THOUGH.
>> CUT!
OKAY.
THAT WAS A GOOD FIRST RUN, GUYS.
TOMMY, MAYBE A LITTLE BETTER
DANCING UP TOP.
>> YEAH, GOT IT.
I CAN DO A LITTLE MORE.
>> NOT REALLY MORE, JUST BETTER.
PERFECT, MARIO.
AND JAMAL, BUDDY, I FEEL LIKE
YOU MAYBE AD LIBBED A BIT AT THE
END.
THE LINE IS THAT'S WHY I
SWITCHED TO DOVATO HIV TREATMENT
THEN FULL STOP.
>> GOT IT.
>> FROM THE TOP.
ACTION!
>> LIVING WITH HIV, I LEARNED I
COULD STAY UNDETECTABLE WITH
FEWER MEDICINES.
>> MOST HIV PILLS HAVE SO MANY
MEDICINES, BUT DOVATO HAS LESS,
AND IT'S JUST AS EFFECTIVE.
>> THAT'S WHY I SWITCHED TO
DOVATO HIV TREATMENT.
FACT, YOU CAN GET HIV FROM A
GIRL.
THAT'S HOW I DID IT.
>> CUT!
AGAIN, AGAIN, WOW.
>> DID I MESS UP THE DANCING?
>> YEAH.
IT WAS WORSE THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN, MARIO, PERFECTION.
AND JAMAL, BUDDY, YOU KNOW WHAT
I'M GOING TO SAY.
>> I MESSED UP THE DANCING.
>> NO.
YOU AD LIBBED AGAIN.
ARE YOU COMFORTABLE WITH THIS
SCRIPT?
>> NO, NOT AT ALL.
>> WHAT'S THE PROBLEM?
>> I FEEL LIKE IT'S NOT CLEAR MY
CHARACTER IS A STRAIGHT GUY
RESPECTFULLY.
>> IT'S NOT.
THIS SCENE TAKES PLACE AT A GAY
CLUB.
>> OH, WORD.
OKAY.
>> YEAH.
IS THAT GOING TO BE A PROBLEM
FOR YOU.
>> NO, NO PROBLEM.
I JUST AIN'T, NO DOUBT.
>> GOOD BECAUSE I WOULD LOVE TO
GET THIS SCENE WRAPPED BEFORE MY
SALAD GETS COLD.
IT'S A HOT SALAD.
AND ACTION.
>> LIVING WITH HIV, I LEARNED I
COULD STAY UNDETECTABLE WITH
FEWER MEDICINES.
>> IT'S A GAY CLUB.
>> WHAT.
>> I MEAN, I'M COOL WITH THAT, I
JUST DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
>> OKAY.
>> FACT.
THERE BE MAD STRAIGHT GIRLS AT
THE GAY CLUBS, AND THEY BE
READY, AND THAT'S WHERE I COME
IN.
>> CAN SOMEBODY PLEASE YELL CUT?
>> CUT.
CUT.
SORRY.
I TOOK A QUICK BITE OF MY HOT
SALAD.
IT BURNED THE ROOF OF MY MOUTH.
>> HOW DID I DO?
>> IT WAS THE WORST THING I'VE
EVER SEEN BESIDES TOMMY'S
DANCING.
>> I'M TRYING.
>> I JUST FEEL LIKE SINCE I'M
STRAIGHT, MY GUY SHOULD BE
STRAIGHT TOO.
>> IT'S JUST ACTING, BRO.
I'M NOT ACTUALLY GAY EITHER.
>> OKAY.
>> JAMAL, IF YOU'RE
UNCOMFORTABLE, WE CAN JUST GIVE
YOUR LINES TO MARIO.
>> DO I STILL GET PAID THE SAME?
>> YOU DON'T GET PAID.
YOU JUST GO HOME.
>> I NEED THIS JOB.
>> THEN SAY THE LINES.
>> WHAT IF MY GUY GOT HIV FROM
BASKETBALL LIKE MAGIC JOHNSON.
>> I APPRECIATE YOU COMING DOWN,
BUT CLEARLY YOU'RE NOT MATURE
ENOUGH TO HANDLE THIS ROLE,
JAMAL.
>> THAT'S A FACT.
>> SO WHY DON'T YOU AND TOMMY
JUST LEAVE, PLEASE?
>> WAIT, ME?